number two going back to the kenosha
story for a minute um
i just saw this before we went on there
lebron james has weighed in
and speaking of someone bsing their way
along sounding like they have no idea
what they're talking about um
here's lebron james i'm smart enough to
know that even though we're playing a
game of basketball that there's so much
more that's going on in the world
so so much more that's even more
important than us playing the game
um and uh to hear what happened to
kenosha today was a
um was a blow to the heart and to the
gut um
you know not only to that community um
you know but to us and to every
um you know i guess you know black
person that that just has
been a part of this process and seeing
these outcomes for so long
and not only just in the black community
but also in the white community as well
who
who who see uh you know moments like
this happen to us
um to happen to his family and to happen
to the kid himself um
to see that verdict it was just um it
was a blow to the gut like i said in the
blow to the heart
but we got to continue to we got to
continue to stay strong
um continue to to to believe in each
other and continue to push for
for the for the greater of change and
for the greater good and uh to hear
uh you know my people turn on in georgia
um in the fashion that they did
um i definitely gonna get some more
information on it but i heard they
turned out in georgia and that's
commendable um it's something that we
started with more than a vote and we
want to continue to do that and continue
to support
you know actions like this and causes
that went on today um
has been going on obviously so i'm proud
of um
you know proud of my people for getting
out there
and doing what they do best so and
that's being heard and being seen
and being powerful and being engaged
yeah this guy has no idea what's going
on he has no clue
that was just one long parade of cliches
uh i'm proud of uh down there in georgia
that the the turnout
and you know the situations that are
going on down there there's all kinds of
situations i'm proud of those situations
there are other situations i'm not proud
of you know those bad situations are
good situations
but i just really i like the good
situations and i'm and um
i'm just so proud of that this guy's
just no clue
no clue what's going on in the world um
and he calls jacob blake a kid
oh you know that poor kid that kid jacob
blake's like 30 years old
a wanted felon 30 years old allegedly
raped a woman
you know assaulted a police or he's just
a just an innocent kid and of course
lebron james we talk about how the woman
is being ignored in all this
uh lebron james that's another one he's
he's never
acknowledged her never said anything
about her doesn't care at all
but the fact that lebron really has no
idea what's going on and doesn't care
that's the point
he doesn't really care you think he
really cares about jacob blake and
what's happening in kenosha
it's not like someone like lebron is uh
is
misguided in it it's really passionate
but he's just a [ __ ] and he's misguided
that that's the i think it's incorrect
to see it that way
i think you're doing him a favor yeah he
might be a [ __ ]
and he might be misguided in many ways
that's not exactly what's happening here
i think he doesn't really care at all
um he's living in his mansion in los
angeles
just kind of casually throwing hand
grenades
into into uh into crowded cities
doing his part to spark rioting and
looting and unrest doesn't care at all
doesn't mean anything to him he just
knows it's kind of a popular thing to
say
and it's getting him some good attention
that he likes
and the right kinds of people are
patting him on the back for it
and so he doesn't care just kind of
casually
yanking the pin out tossing the grenade
doesn't matter to him
guy's a sociopath a lot of those out
there
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content